this country is continuing to make
progress in the fight against kovid
we're proceeding with our roadmap and i
want to thank everybody
for continuing to follow the guidance
and to thank parents and families for
the incredible work
you're doing to help test pupils through
the easter holidays and
to encourage you to keep testing them
twice a week as schools return
and above all i want to thank everybody
involved in the outstanding vaccine
rollout
especially those of you coming forwards
in huge numbers
as you are 19 out of 20 of those who
have had a first dose
are coming forward for a second meaning
that almost one in five
adults have now had a second dose and
on first jabs we've now vaccinated 33
million people
including 60 of the 45
to 49 year olds and we know
that this vaccination program is making
a big difference
we know that it's helping to reduce
suffering and save lives
potentially on a on a very big scale but
we don't
yet know the full extent of the
protection
that we're building up the exact
strength
of our defenses and as we look at what's
happening in other countries with cases
now record numbers uh around the world
we cannot delude ourselves that covid
has gone away
i see nothing in the data now
that makes me think we are going to have
to
deviate in any way from the road map
cautious but irreversible that we have
set out
but the majority of scientific opinion
in this country is still firmly of the
view
that there will be another wave of covid
at some stage
this year and so we must as far as
possible learn to live with this disease
as we live with other
diseases we'll be bolstering our
defenses with booster jabs
this awesome this autumn i will be
continuing
with testing and today i want to
announce
what we hope will be a further line of
medical
defense the united kingdom was the first
country in the world
to pioneer dexamethasone which has saved
a million lives globally and today
we're creating a new antivirals task
force
to search for the most promising new
medicines and support
their development through clinical
trials with the aim of making them
safely and rapidly available as early
as the autumn this means for example
that
if you test positive there might be a
tablet you could take at home
to stop the virus in its tracks
and significantly reduce the chance
of infection turning into more severe
disease
or if you're living with someone who has
tested
positive there might be a pill you could
take
for a few days to stop you getting the
disease yourself
and by focusing on these antivirals
these new antivirals
we hope to lengthen the uk's lead in in
medicines and in life sciences
and to give ever greater confidence to
the people of this country
that we continue on our path towards
freedom
we've taken a big step again this month
reopening
significant parts of our country and for
many people
this last week has brought the first
glimmerings of a return
to normality having a pint having a
haircut making that
trip to the shops every day
science is helping us to get
back towards normality and i believe
that
antiviral treatments can play an
important part
and if we keep going follow the rules
remember hands
face space fresh air then we can
keep each other safe and see through our
road map
to reclaim our lives in full